thank you
roughly a year after Jen Shaw pled
guilty to federal fraud charges The Real
Housewives of Salt Lake City Star
reported to prison day one of her six
and a half year term Behind Bars
Jen offered an apology at her sentencing
hearing last month quote my actions have
hurt innocent people I am profoundly and
deeply sorry a source telling ET at the
time Jen was ready to serve her time and
put everything behind her I have some
bad news oh my God there's police and
they have handcuffs out after cameras
captured this Infamous moment in season
2 of the reality show Bravo chronicled
Jen's legal troubles if the worst thing
happens and I'm feeling guilty like
can you please check on my family the
season three finale documenting the
countdown to her trial which of course
never happened nuts because after
nearly two years of professing her
innocence I'm not gonna take a plea deal
when I'm not guilty I'm innocent Jen
pled guilty to conspiracy to commit wire
fraud I didn't want to believe
that Jen was capable of doing any of
that it was the last thing I expected
everything really changed when she pled
guilty and my focus just immediately
went to the victims and the restitution
that you know she's working to get back
to them when I realized that I'd been
had
I was devastated those victims sharing
their stories with ABC News I started
this process in March and by the end of
September I had spent over twenty nine
thousand dollars Jen's vowed to make
good on what she owes nine million
dollars
she's facing 10 plus years in jail The
Fallout carried over to the Salt Lake
reunion filmed before Jen was sentenced
yeah I don't know why you would sign up
to be a housewife I don't either we're
running a telemarketing scheme I
honestly thought that she would fight it
to the end I was shocked I didn't see it
coming because she has said that she's
innocent I mean that's what she's been
screaming at the top of her lungs you
have no feeling about this whatsoever I
think it's absolutely
terrible and got wrenching I can't speak
to anything regarding her innocence or
guilt though what do you make of people
going on TV when they truly have so much
to lose it just shows you that like
people are obsessed with Fame to the
point where they're willing to go to
jail for it because that's the one thing
you can't buy reality TV's Crossover
with the justice system is a bit of a
trend like with another housewife Teresa
Giudice it's like always other people
gotta get involved but the Real
Housewives of New Jersey star who spent
a year in prison after pleading guilty
to multiple fraud charges in 2014 is not
here for any gen shot comparisons it's
sad like I wouldn't steal anybody's
money that's so mean Jen leaves behind
her husband known as coach two children
and a snowflake the show moving forward
is going to look different there's a big
hole Yeah
do you think the show can survive
without her I think
Housewives can survive without any of us
it's its own sight guys it's its own
force and Salt Lake City is a small
insular very culturally
intriguing situation and so I think if
you can get women to put their lives on
camera from Salt Lake City you'll always
have a franchise there